Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and hopefully
you’ve had a chance to see the Book 3 finale.
Because it’s two episodes together I’m
going to make this a top 10 video. I know
a lot of you still have big questions about
Book 4 with all the changes and the show moving
to digital only. Don’t worry, they’re
finishing book 4 and it will also be all digital.
No official release date yet. But plan for
next summer until we hear otherwise.
I’ll explain what kind of Avatar and Korra
videos I’m doing now that the season is
over. But the giveaway will still run for
another week. All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment.
Here we go, TOP 10 moments from the Korra
finale, careful for spoilers in case you haven’t
seen it yet. I’ll wait just a sec….Here
We go.
Number 10 - Korra decides to give herself
up
There were a lot of Last Airbender parallels
with the way the finale went down. Korra making
the hard choice to turn herself in really
reminded me of Sozin’s Comet Part 2 where
Aang had run off to meditate and came to the
conclusion he would have to kill Ozai which
was completely against all of his beliefs
as an airbender.
Korra makes the choice with no assurance she’ll
survive. I like that they made that clear.
She’s the gung-ho avatar, which is like
the polar opposite of Aang who was the reluctant
Avatar. So she’s just going to leave it
up to her friends to rescue her in an attempt
to bargain herself for the safety of the airbenders.
I feel like if any of you have friends who
think Korra has been a selfish Avatar should
reference this as an example of Korra being
very not selfish. If you’re trying to argue
with them about it.
Moving on to Number 9 - Tenzin is NOT Dead
This made me so happy. He’s such a guiding
force not just for Korra herself, but for
the series in general. Losing him would be
like losing your compass in the South Pole.
The only person I feel could help guide Korra
and serve as a spiritual guide for the audience
would be Jinora or Zuko. Based on the way
the finale presented her I would say Jinora
is definitely the future.
I’ll talk more about her as I work through
the list.
Number 8 - The Doublecross
This was one of the most creative uses of
Waterbending I’ve seen. Book 2 pushed it
futher than I’d ever see it go before with
the water drills. But Ming Hua or Grey Delisle
if you want to think about her that way. Pushed
the limits of waterbending the same way Zaheer
pushed airbending.
Aside from crazy healing powers, I don’t
know what deep mythological abilities might
apply to water. We’ve already seen crazy
powerful bloodbending from Amon and Avatar
Last Airbender spent a lot of time showcasing
Katara’s special abilities.
I guess that’s kind of what Ming Hua has
been for book 3. Like a super evil version
of Katara. We never really got to see Katara
in her prime as an adult so it would be hard
to say who’s the more gifted waterbender.
And I don’t think Ming Hua would have had
the spirituality necessary for unlocking secret
abilities that went beyond subbending.
But Number 7 - Team Beifong Takes Out P’Li
One of the coolest takedowns all season. Metalbending
her armor around her head so the blast would
splatter her brains. Let me know if you think
there has been a more violent kill so far.
The Earth Queen was like slow agony so I guess
you could say she had a more gruesome death.
Which Zaheer confirmed when he pushed Korra’s
father off the cliff. I was happy he said
it out loud. So we can confirm no Earth Queen
in book 4.
The whole fight scene was amazing and the
animation. There were a lot of specific animation
techniques I noticed that went way above and
beyond so I’ll try to mention them when
I talk about each of these big moments.
Korra fighting while handcuffed as really
badass too.
Number 6 - Zaheer Can Fly
This is where shit really got crazy. All of
the Guru Laghima stuff made sense, it was
a literal thing. Meaning the void was more
of a spiritual vacuum for emotion and earthly
attachment.
It’s a big callback to Last Airbender’s
Guru Pathik who tried to get Aang to leave
earthly attachment behind. That was all about
energy bending. But the chakras and Guru Laghima’s
teachings make me wonder if all bending has
a certain spiritual energy connected to it.
The way the show presents bending is as being
very separate. But when all the lessons start
to sound like the same lesson you start to
wonder. Like everyone is tending the same
garden, some just focus on different areas
of it based on their personality.
That doesn’t really take the Lion Turtles
into account but let me know if you think
that Book 4 will build on all the new things
we’ve learned about Bending Science.
Ooh, Bending Science, that actually sounds
like a class they should teach at Republic
City University.
The Zaheer P’li moment was really bittersweet
and despite him being looney tunes, I think
his emotions for her were completely genuine.
He wasn’t manipulating her or anything.
Mike and Bryan just needed the scene to show
that once she was dead, Zaheer no longer had
any earthly tethers. Thus, he achieved flight.
Did anyone else think he was walking on the
clouds when the camera panned down and showed
him, just for a sec it seemed like he would
walk away on the clouds.
His flight animation was also really amazing,
I feel like they really capture the physics
of how an airbender would move through the
air.
I think he was airbending himself. He wasn’t
airbending the air molecules around him. That’s
just my interpretation though.
I know Jinora’s spirit projection is supposed
to be the sub form of airbending but did anyone
else think that Zaheer’s weightlessness
was actually what it was.
I kind of think it’s like Earthbending having
two sub forms. Lava and Metal. So now Air
has two sub forms. Astral Projection and Flight.
Number 5 - Bolin Lavabends
I think we all collectively felt he would
learn a subform this season. I actually thought
it would be metal bending. I would have liked
it better if Ghazan had taught him how to
do it but I guess there just wasn’t enough
time to give them that character arc.
There was that awesome part during Book 1
where Tenzin taught Korra about Airbending,
it was so detailed in his description of where
you have to go emotionally in order to do
it. I feel like there’s still a lot about
Lavabending I still don’t understand because
we haven’t gotten that ‘lesson’ episode.
It’s super rare, so I don’t see someone
explaining it to him in Book 4, unless it’s
someone in the fire nation. And yes, I do
think they’ll go back to the fire nation
in Book 4. Remember all the airbenders will
be nomadic.
The only heartbreaking thing about Bolin’s
big moment was the destruction of the Northern
Air temple. It’s like watching someone destroy
a priceless piece of art. You just cringe
at the thought.
Even though the air nomads will be roaming,
I still think the temple will be rebuilt eventually.
But Number 4 - Zaheer Tries To Kill Korra
In the Avatar State
This was a huge callback to the Last Airbender
Book 2 finale. Especially with all the green
crystals around. The outcome was essentially
the same. Aang went into a coma, effectively
rendering him inert until Book 3 and Korra
is severely disabled.
When they said poison I didn’t realize it
was metal poison. But technically any kind
of metal in your body would poison you. So
I don’t think it’s really important what
kind of poison it was.
The thing I really noticed aside from the
cave which was both beautiful and terrifying
was the Dai Li agents. The Red Lotus has members
inside the Dai Li. Making me wonder if The
Red Lotus guided a lot of the Earth Queen’s
mistakes. Like counseled her to make decisions
that would set the Earth Kingdom on the path
to destruction.
I’ll talk more about that in my book 4 predictions
video.
I had thought before this all went down that
part of this idea of Entering the Void might
be some sort of journey into death. Which
is naturally me just overthinking things.
Who else flipped a little when they saw the
animation on Korra, especially her face as
the poison started to take effect. I love
the way Studio Mir pushed Korra in a more
Anime direction this year. It makes me feel
like we’ll see more of the same in Book
4.
Mike and Bryan already said that another studio
was helping finish book 4, but Studio Mir
is animating pretty much every episode. They’re
just getting a little bump to get everything
out by next year.
Into top 3 now, Number 3 - Jinora and the
Airbenders rescue Korra
One of the coolest uses of Bending all season.
It reminds you that there are still a lot
of creative innovations in bending that we
have not seen yet. I’m really interested
to see if we see some unusual firebending
in the fire nation in book 4.
I felt like this was a big callback to Jinora
rescuing Raava in the book 2 finale. Which
makes me feel like Mike and Bryan are positioning
her for a spin off comic or at least presenting
her as the future of the Avatar Universe when
they stop telling Korra driven stories.
Like the way Zuko became the central figure
in the Search comic. I feel like there’s
potential for a Jinora story in the comics.
On to Number 2 - Korra vs Zaheer
This is Korra in auto Avatar State mode. She
reminded me a lot of Aang back in Book 1 when
he first learned that the Air Nation had been
massacred and he flipped out so hardcore that
he went into the avatar state and almost no
one could talk him down.
Since then both Last Airbender and Korra have
done a good job of explaining the postives
and negatives of being in the avatar state.
It’s so powerful that your conscious mind
gets suppressed a little and you literally
become a force of nature. So if you’re not
highly trained the potential for collateral
damage is really high. And you become super
vulnerable.
I don’t totally buy into the logic that
dying in the avatar state ends the cycle.
I think it’s just a story device that keeps
the Avatar from becoming an unkillable hero.
In order for there to be dramatic tension,
a writing perspective.
think about as they fought while flying after
each other. I loved the twist that Korra was
using fire bending to fly like Ozai and Zaheer
used airbending like Aang.
Just another twist on a classic. And then
just to call it back to Aang again, when Beifong
earthbended Zaheer’s prison. It was just
like the scene where Aang took Yakone’s
bending.
And my favorite moment - Jinora’s Ceremony
I will freely admit to crying a little. This
was probably the best callback to Last Airbender
or at least my favorite. When Aang got his
ceremony at the end of Book 1. He was accepting
his role as the Avatar and Jinora was accepting
her role as the new spiritual leader of the
Air Nation.
Just to clarify, I think Tenzin was explaining
that Jinora would be in charge and he would
just be counseling her. This is a huge payoff
to the father daughter relationship story
they had this year. It’s him acknowledging
her abilities and maturity.
I feel like this season would be a great story
arc for any of you girls out there to watch
with your dad’s. Especially if you want
to get your parents into Avatar.
I have a lot of thoughts about Book 4 which
I’ll mostly save for my predictions video.
I’ll try and post that tonight while everything
is fresh in our heads.
But let me know what your favorite moments
were and let me know what your first reaction
was after finishing the episodes.
I think the first thing I did was post a picture
of Aang crying. That was my immediate reaction,
lots of crying.
Overall, both finale episodes were a solid
A plus, I loved the way they altered all the
characters, I thought the narrative was a
lot more engaging and cohesive than previous
seasons and they continued to push the boundaries
of animation on the series.
Just to talk about that a little more. Mike
and Bryan did this podcast recently which
I’ll add a link in the description too.
It was brilliant. But amongst many things,
they explained the way they like to run their
shows. Letting animators be animators, based
on the style they want for Korra.
For example, on most Animated shows in the
united states. The overseas animators are
very limited to what they can do. Like they’re
not allowed to be real animators, they have
to adhere to such strict rules for drawing
scenes.
But Mike and Bryan with Korra have tried to
find a way to allow some creativity back into
the process. Mostly by finding animators that
could pull off what they had in mind and allowing
new ideas in during the animation process.
I think that’s why the Beifong flashbacks
looked so amazing, they were a totally different
animation style than normal korra episodes.
And you wouldn’t see that on a typical animated
children’s show. It’s just a good example
of the attention they give to the creative
process and I think it’s one of the best
things about the Avatar series.
Most of the feelings I have about the series
right now are optimistic. They were pretty
clear that after Book 4 they would not be
animating another avatar series. They’d
be doing something, just not Avatar. It’s
all in that podcast.
Speaking of which, they disseminated so much
information that I’m going to do another
bonus video in the next couple of days that’s
my Mike and Bryan Top 10 Moments. It’s all
cool behind the scenes stuff. They even explain
what happened with the Avatar Movie from M
Night.
The most interesting thought that I’ll leave
you guys with is that Mike and Bryan said
because the animation process takes so long,
they’ve already wrapped up everything that
you have big questions about. Any hanging
plotline or character you feel got dropped.
Like Azula for instance. They have all addressed
in future Book 4 stories.
So leave book 3 knowing that all of your questions
will be addressed in those episodes.
Like I said though, I’ll explain what I
think is going on in my predictions video.
I’ll try to post that tonight.
I know there’s a bunch of Doctor Who stuff
I’m working on too so I’ll try to get
it all out as fast as possible.
Right now click here for Book 4 predictions.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And click here for my next Korra Q&A. I might
not be able to post that till Monday.
Thanks for watching, I’ll still be crying
with you guys tonight. Let’s all go hug
our sky bison.